well was back this week I was most
definitely Rusty but it's all good
sometimes you need games like that to
get
humble get refocused and that's exactly
what I needed so me and the team going
to go back to work go back to the
drawing board and come out and try to go
undefeated these last couple
games so we gonna get we get back right
I mean we did the best we could do you
know I was still Rusty still getting
back into the groove of things but we
gonna fix it we gonna get it right ain't
nothing but a little little adversity
that's all it is all right I know it
went down y'all know it went down in the
game had coach Prime he didn't hold back
and yeah so we
got you're not going to be taken care of
you're not going to be looked after
you're not going to have the luxuries
all this and you going to have to go out
there and get it on your own and work
your butt off because ain't nobody going
to give you nothing I don't understand I
don't think you understand what this
world is consist
of what we just did today was
pathetic all the love that you received
all the love we receive oh you getting
ready to see that flip and don't get
beside yourself on social media and
start responding to the foolishness
because they're
right they're
right and we practic
more God
bless have a wonderful night how going
I'm doing good yeah that practice the
next day was crazy
though boy we had we only got a couple
hours to sleep for real woke up TR to go
back to practice but that's what we
needed though had to get us back on the
right track and nobody pay attention to
the media anyways we let people talk
when we lose or when we win it doesn't
bother us it doesn't get to us I just
let him talk I really don't
care I know I got to go get back in and
go to work that's it